- La science est sans équivoque:
pour limiter le réchauffement
de la planète à 1,5 degré et
ainsi assurer un futur viable
pour les générations à venir,
il n'y plus de place
pour l'expansion des énergie
fossiles.
L'utilisation du charbon,
du pétrole et du gaz doit être
réduite respectivement de 100 %,
60 % et 70 % d'ici 2050
par rapport aux niveaux de 2019.
Selon les scientifiques,
le sommet des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre,
qui sont toujours en croissance,
devrait être atteint en 2teint ,
et d'ici 2030, chuter de 43 %.
Le défi est colossal.
Mais la bonne nouvelle,
c'est que des solutions
efficaces sont à portée de main.
EDDY PEREZ, diplomatie clima
internat., Réseau Action Climat
- Il nous dit que jusqu'à 10 %
des émissions des gaz à effet
de serre peuvent être retirées
si on arsubventionner
l'industrie pétrolière.
- Et depuis 2010, le coût de
déploiement de l'énergie solaire
production de batteries
lithium-ion ont diminué de 85 %.
Celui de l'énergie éolienne
a baissé de 55 %. De quoi
convainc"÷,Z/O dans cette direcÑ
Le secrétaire général de l'ONU
n'a pas manqué d'envoyer
un message clair à ceux
qui résistent.
Nous sommes un grand maître du
de gaz.
Le secrétaire général de l'ONU
n'a pas manqué d'envoyerun messx
qui résistent.
Et si l'argent a l'habitude
de mener le monde, le rapport
du GIEC confirme que sur le long
terme, il est tout aussi
rentable d'investir
dans des solutions vertes
et que le coût humain
de l'inaction devrait convaincre
les sceptiques.
JEAN-PASERSELE,
ancien président du GIEC
- Le GIEC dit encore une fois,
cette fois-ci, que le coût
de la protection du climatest it
des dommages que l'on pourrait
éviter si on se mettait
à protéger le climat.
- Les solutions sont nombreuses
et touchent toutes les sphères
de notre vie, de la gestion
de l'étalement urbain
à nos modes de transport, et
jusqu'au choix de ts.ts.ts.ts.t.
L'outil pour y arriver, disent
les scientifiques : utiliser de
la psychologie comportementale.
Autrement dit : comment
convaincre tous et chacun
de faire sa part au quotidien.
FRANÇOIS DELORME, prof. sciences
économ., École de gestion, UdeS
- Le GIEC mentionne
l'architecture des choix,
qui est un outil en économie
comportementale qui permet,
en facilitant les choix,
en adoucissant la transition,
de grimper la même montagne,
mais avec une pente un peu
plus facile.
- La sobriété devrait maintenant
guider nos choix.
Ici Elisa Serret,
Radio-Canada, Mon